this was the fifth day of ryan giggs's
trial at manchester crown court and it
focused on the events of november 1st
2020. that was the night his
then-girlfriend kate grevel alleges that
the former footballer forcibly
head-butted her here the home they
shared in greater manchester
the jury were played 999 calls made to
the police by miss greville's younger
sister emma who was at the house at the
time
please can you come quickly emma
greville tells the operator you can hear
screaming and shouting in the background
of the call he's head-butted her in the
face
later she's heard shouting to someone
you try to hurt her you hurt her
the operator tries to establish the
identity of those involved what's his
name the operator asks ryan giggs she
says as in the ryan giggs the footballer
ryan giggs she replies
several officers then arrived at mr
giggs's house about 10 minutes after
those 999 calls one officer said that mr
giggs had blood around his mouth and
that miss greville had swollen lips with
significant bruising body cam footage
was then shown to the jury which showed
mr giggs telling an officer that the
couple had been out in manchester that
they'd been drinking and when they got
home they began to argue during that
they'd taken each other's phones and
they were rowing with each other to get
them back
he told the officer we got into a little
bit of a tangle she kicked me in the
head
there's been a struggle but i've hit her
on the lip
when the officer asked mr giggs if this
is the same version of events that ms
greville would recount mr giggs replies
she's going to say i've hit her
more police footage captured mr giggs
being arrested that night he denies
charges of assault and coercive behavior
towards kate greville and the assault of
her sister emma the trial continues on
monday
catherine of autopsy sky news manchester